an unequal battle is brewing in the
german parliament the bundestag one that
pits a gigantic ruling coalition against
a shrunken opposition
the christian democrats were the clear
winners of the election
if they form a coalition with the social
democrats some eighty percent of seats
will be theirs
this would leave little room for the
greens and the left party
we're all allah to see if a grand
coalition really does come about if it
does we'll be left powerless and that is
not acceptable
the christian democrats and the social
democrats were flexing their muscles at
the first parliamentary meeting it's
standard practice for each parliamentary
group to put forward one vice president
but now the cdu and spd say they each
want two
the greens have protested but the spd is
brushing them off
we both did poorly in the election but
our 25.7
is quite a bit more than 8.4 as the
greens must realize an unequal partner
can't expect equal treatment
that's not what minority protection is
about
the greens parliamentary group leader
catherine girling eckhart worries that
this is just a taste of things to come
they're playing the situation to their
advantage suddenly they're capable of
reaching a quick agreement but there's
no obvious reason why we need more vice
presidents
germany's constitution the basic law
guarantees the rights of the opposition
but the left party and greens together
hold just 20 percent of the seats
that falls short of the 25 quorum needed
to establish a parliamentary inquiry or
call a special session
the opposition
the opposition has specific rights and
an important role to play in our
democracy if we're being excluded
because we don't hold enough seats we
need a new solution
when the basic law was drafted its
authors made sure the opposition would
have the tools needed to monitor and
rein in the governing parties
those checks and balances they believed
were necessary to ensure democracy
germany's basic law makes sure that the
opposition has enough power to take
action
that's what parliamentary minority
rights are for
some countries don't have them
the right to set up an inquiry for
example isn't guaranteed to minorities
everywhere
it's one of our major achievements we
had it in the weimar republic in west
germany and it's still in place today
the cdu in particular has no desire to
amend the basic law they argue the 25
hurdle is there for a reason
and we have to remember that in theory
this parliament could have left-wing and
even right-wing extremists who are up to
no good
their main goal would be to undermine
the parliamentary process and with the
democracy
so they would be happy to use every tool
at their disposal to undermine our
parliament
we need these hurdles to make sure that
splinter groups won't bring our
parliament to a standstill
the president of the bundestag agrees
this could be a serious risk in a press
conference he suggested a different
solution amending the parliamentary
procedure that way even a tiny
opposition could launch an inquiry or
call a special session without a
constitutional amendment
the election result is what it is
although i do have sympathy for their
complaint and i've said that many times
we have to accept that these are the
rules
the parliament reflects the vote of the
electorate
and not some theoretical ideal of the
perfect democratic structure
small as it is the opposition is putting
up a fight it's not prepared to be
dependent on the goodwill of a grand
coalition
they can't just say let's see what we
can do for you we need to be able to
enforce our rights before the courts if
need be
the first parliamentary session and the
first disagreement it's more than just a
minor skirmish what's at stake is a key
element of parliamentary democracy
you